hello everyone my channel is very close
to hitting seventy thousand subscribers
and today I thought to myself seventy
thousand people is a lot of people you
know when I say something stupid I say
something stupid in front of at least
seventy thousand people if I blunder in
a video I blunder in front of 70,000
people but then again there there is an
upside to this I did I did a pretty hard
work this past few months you know
promoting chess but then it hit me
you know seventy thousand people I
thought I'd give you a very nice
challenge the idea is that you can also
promote chess now what did I have in
mind pick anyone pick anyone who doesn't
play chess be it your father your mother
your brother your sister
boyfriend/girlfriend really anyone even
a stranger in the park if you okay if
you're very young don't go to the near
strangers in the park but it can be
literally anyone and try to get them
interested in chess I thought there's a
seventy thousand subscribers here if if
if every one of you gets at least one
person interested in chess there could
be seventy thousand more new chess
players in 2018 practically in a couple
of days and what I thought you could do
commemorate this moment of you teaching
the other person chest with a photo or
with a short video and you after you do
a photo or a short video you can do you
can do whatever you want in that video
it doesn't have to be long like 20
seconds you can wish everyone happy
holidays or you can just send any
message to the world that that you want
to be that you want the world to hear
and those photos and videos I want you
to send them to me
there will be an email in the
description below its subscribers dot
videos that are good matter at gmail.com
but you don't have to remember it it
will be the first thing you see in the
description you can just copy paste it
and then just you know send me your
photo or video and then after I receive
all those photos or videos if any of you
will be interested in this
I will then around New Year I will edit
all of those photos and videos into one
single
with some nice you know happy music and
then I will run it on my channel so you
can share your joy of playing chess and
teaching chess with the rest with the
rest of the community
so yeah that's basically the idea I will
do a separate video on this just you
know try and attract more people to
promote chess but that being said now
let's get back to this game it's a quite
an interesting game because we have a
Sahaba secure of India he's rated
somewhere around 1700 and probably
30-something and we have a grandmaster
Adam Takaya
of Ukraine he is rated somewhere around
twenty five hundred and seventy five so
there is almost 850 low points
difference in rating between them and
Adam to cap here is definitely one of
the favorites to win this tournament if
not the favorite and this is round 1 of
the tournament he faces 10 year-old
Sahara Vostok now two days ago III shown
you mine get my game against the
Grandmaster and I played terrible in
that game so now you will see how to
play against the Grandmaster by watching
how ten year old by sock plays against
him so Sahab that has the white pieces
in he opens with E 4 we have c5 Knight
to f3 d6 with a d4 see Curtis Knight
captures and Knight to c6 the tamaño
variation
Knight to c3 b6 now Bishop to e3 and a6
Bishop to e2 Knight f6 both sides simply
developing Sahara castles Bishop to e7
and Knight to b3 white could go for the
main line which is f4 but Knight to b3
is also an idea avoiding avoiding the
trade of pieces here are on castles we
have f4 now b5 + a3 preventing the early
be for Bishop to b7 Bishop to f3 now
reinforcing the e4 pawn rook to c8 and
Queen to e1 Queen to c7 now rook to d1
and rook F to e8
Quinta g3 transferring the Queen to the
Kings side Bishop to a8 we have a queen
to f2 now with some ideas of Bishop to
b6 maybe if life isn't careful maybe if
he plays something like rook to the 8th
but you know it's a nice-nice pressuring
tool
Queen Queen to b8 getting the Queen out
of there G for now and we have a 5 here
and there wasn't really a need for this
a5 it's it's a bit too soon okay Black's
idea is a 5 B 4 but since this Queen and
Bishop are exerting a lot of pressure
here so maybe maybe a better approach
would be something like Knights to d7
followed by Bishop to d8 and Bishop to
b6 - to exchange some pieces but ok Adam
one for a five and we have g5 now Knight
to d7 and Bishop to g4 before now a
capture some before a capture some
before and Knight to e2 Bishop to f8 and
here comes Knights 2g 3G six now and
this is the critical moment in the game
this is very important this is a very
important position just so you can see
how how mature young so hard the 10 year
old player is there are a lot of
interesting choices here for white for
example some of you would think this is
a good way to break through with f5 but
f5 actually doesn't work because of
because of knight Knight to e5 and after
it captures captures the knight is
happily protecting f7 there is no Queen
to f7 idea here also he's attacking the
bishop at g4 and after something like
Bishop here Bishop to g7 and now the
rope is coming to f8 and the position is
perfectly fine for black so after this
g6 move a young so hard plate
e5 and this is this is a this is a wild
move now you can't capture the pawn if D
captures e5 you lose the Knights at the
night and d7 is unprotected but even
better if you push d5 which seems like a
totally reasonable move you get rook
captures on d5 rook pawn captures rook
and our Bishop captures night on d7
attacking both ropes you'll win back the
exchange and you'll be up upon with a
better position so it's not
an easy choice for black here after this
if I move Adam decided to go for night
to d8e captures on d6 and we have h5 now
Bishop to f3 Bishop captures Queen
captures and rook captures and c2 black
wins back the pawn Knight to e4 now
Knight the b7 and rook to f2 I'm going
for the exchange of rooks rook F to see
a doubling up on the C file rope
captures rook captures and night the D
for bringing the night into the game
which tempo given up the beat you up on
it
if black wishes to capture it Adam
didn't capture it if you capture the
pawn you get some knight c6 ideas with a
temple on the Queen and then you have
this knife is threatening to come to e7
this Knight is threatening to come to f6
a lot of threats for a single pawn so
Adam doesn't go for this he plays Rock
the c8 and here we have Queen to h3 and
Queen to h3 is an interesting move there
there was the idea of actually playing
f5 here what are Salvador considered at
5:00 or not it's hard to say what would
happen is something like e captures on
f5 and Knight captures on f5 of course
you have to sacrifice a piece G capture
screen captures and after Knight
captures tonight captures and Bishop
captures and g6 it's a it's a very wild
position white sacrificed a piece but
it's it's not at all clear if black and
defenders for example rook f8 you grab
back the piece if black decides to
defend which he must so something like
Bishop Bishop captures h2 King h1 and
it's it's a pretty wild position
probably black and hold this so maybe
maybe so hard o consider this and
decided not to go for this wild eight f5
idea
he played Queen to h3 night to d8 now
and this night to d8 is a pretty slow
move the straight forward Knight
captures on d6 is actually perfectly
fine for black but okay Adam plays
Knight to d8 and we have Knight to f3
now Queen to a8 and here comes Queen 28
comes with a threat of capturing the
knight on e4 and here young Soeharto
plays Knight to e5 and this is
this is you know he's really torturing
the grand master always always giving
him variations to consider now you have
to kind of capture this night if you
capture this night for example night
captures here you get night of six check
King h8 and now F captures on e5 and so
it's a clearly a better position for
white this dark square Bishop is
completely locked in you you have a nice
pass pawn on d6 black has to be very
careful here so after Knight to e5
Grandmaster to kind of captured the
night here
now comes Knight character son b7 the
threat is of course Knight to f6 for
King the king and the Queen so Bishop to
g7 defending we have Knight to f6 check
Bishop captures G captures and rook to
c2 and it's a pretty again it's it's a
wild position White has to be very
careful the Queen the Queen can't really
go anywhere from h3 especially you know
on the dark square because Queen to g2
will be checkmate
so d7 is played and already this pawn is
very close now
this Knight basically can't move the
knight moves simply promote to a queen
with check and it's game over
Queen to c6 now and this Queen to c6 is
a the third questionable move by the
Grandmaster in this game the straight
forward rook captures on b2 again
followed by b3 b2 which probably would
have probably been better but he was for
Queen to c6 and okay Queen to g3 the to
Cal was in in time trouble so it's
probably he had something to consider
other than capturing the point but okay
now he captures the rook after somebody
to Bishop to f2 now cutting off the
rooks influence in g2 so now there is no
more Queen to G to checkmate
Queen to c2 we have rook to f1 defending
the bishop so the Queen can move Queen
to a5 and we have Bishop to b6 and it's
in this position that the Ukrainian
Grandmaster captured the f6 pawn but
before he could actually hit the clock
his time ran out and in this position
he lost the game because his time ran
out but after this Queen captures on f6
it's actually a winning game for white
for example Queen to g5 the Queen can go
anywhere the knife will be hanging so
you have to exchange Queens and now your
knight is under attack on d8 you can't
really defend it so you have to move it
now comes Queen with check you have to
capture capture so okay black does have
does have three points for the piece but
this dark square bishop and this pawn
can actually control the entire Kings
side but you'll see what I mean by this
it's actually it's actually easily
winning for example b3 now Bishop to f6
would a temple on the rook rook moves
rook to be one now threatening to
capture to b3 pawn the rook can defend
it but now it's a it's a really passive
piece for example King f2 now the king
is coming for the pawn King f8 King III
King e8 but now rugby one threatening
Rob d8 checkmate so the rock would have
to move rook e8 now simply King goes
further in huge threat on the pawn rook
defence and now the King goes for the
pawn checks
King grabs it checks King defense you
can you you can never exchange rooks
because it's a winning game for black so
it would it would only take time once
white accomplishes this task of winning
the b3 pawn and then it's a basically a
winning game but it never got to this
sense after this Queen captures on f6
this is here sorry Queen captures on f6
in this position
Ukrainian Grandmaster Adam took I've
lost the game on time so yeah it's a
it's a great victory I mean in round one
you face the Grandmaster raided 850
points above your your own rating and
you win that game so it's quite an
outstanding achievement and you know I
can only imagine how young basak felt
when he won this game yeah
congratulations to ten year old so hard
Abbas sock I do hope you enjoyed this
game I would like to thank Tony more
guitar Miroslav brada and
shall suit for a contribution to my
channel thank a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon and
like I said there is an email in the
description below feel free to use it
send me your videos your photos and in
the end I will edit a nice big happy
video to share with everyone on my
channel so yeah thank you all and I will
see you soon